Починається обстріл - коти одразу під ліжко ховаються.
Навіть далеко відчувають. Така особливість.
Тут, на лінії фронту неподалік Донецька, періодично стріляють. Це вже повсякдення.
Повсякдення, яка триває майже вісім років. Безхатні тварини,
місцеві жителі та українська армія до цього звикли.
Ось тут живуть, ось тут, на мою думку, живуть. І все. Далі там уже нікого немає.
Більшість із тих, хто залишився, - люди похилого віку, яким немає куди їхати.
Проросійські сепаратисти знаходяться лише за кількасот метрів від українських позицій.
Це так близько, що видно, як там готують обід чи рубають дрова.
Ми приїхали за кілька хвилин після перестрілки. За словами українських вояків,
останнім часом почастішали обстріли снайперів та атаки безпілотників.
Тоді як на Заході стурбовані масовим перекиданням російських військ,
Олександр, як і його побратими, розуміють, що в разі наступу,
перший удар вони візьмуть на себе.
Всі чекають, але знову ж таки, момент підготовки. Ми зараз готові. Це не 14-ий рік.
Нервозність більша (у місцевого населення).
У магазин заходиш - бабусі переживають найбільше.
Ось він - високовольтний стовп. Він ще наш.
І там за високовольтним стовпом ще метрів 30-40 наші. Відвоювали трохи.
Коли ми вперше зустрілися з Катериною та її дітьми у 2017 році,
бої йшли прямо біля її будинку. Тоді лінія фронту розпочиналася там,
де закінчувався її сад. Нині, каже вона, спокійний день, майже не стріляють.
Буває йдемо по селищу, автомат працює, а ми йдемо на своїй хвилі. Ми не боїмося.
У Катерини троє дітей. За кілька тижнів має народитися четверта дитина.
Незважаючи на війну, життя продовжується. Для її родини - тут їхній рідний дім.
Хоча Катерина і розуміє, що багато хто не може собі уявити життя в таких умовах.
Яке б не було селище, воно твоє. Ти вже тут усі манівці знаєш.
Починають бомбити, біжиш городами, ти вже знаєш, де впасти. Тебе вже не вб'ють.
Тим не менше, після стількох років життя на передовій Катерина теж хотіла б виїхати звідси.
Через війну на Донбасі понад 2 мільйони українців були змушені
залишити свої домівки. Тож багато собак і кішок стали безпритульними.
Солдати на передовій підгодовують та зігрівають їх.
Тварини ж віддячують своїм передчуттям небезпеки. Якщо буде обстріл,
вони відчувають та ховаються. І тим самим рятують життя вояків,
а також знімають стрес.
Коли прийшов з поста, лягаєш на ліжко і приходить Чернуха, лягає на живіт:
гладь мене, викидай свій телефон, краще мене погладь. Це як заспокійливе діє.
Зінка завжди поруч. Куди Микита - туди й вона.
Фактично Зінка так само на службі, як і солдати на передовій.
У неї гарний слух, як і в кожного собаки. З нею надійніше ходити на пост.
Якщо супротивник на підході, собака одразу гавкає, ричить,
набагато надійніше і спокійніше.
Від побуту - до геополітики. Запитую в Олександра, чи зможе Україна
попри перешкоджання Кремля, вступити в НАТО.
Не завтра або післязавтра, але, я думаю, приймуть. Багато чого змінилося
і в нас (в армії), і люди змінилися.
Вони вже самі зробили, щоб ми їх не вважали братнім народом.
А поки військовий конфлікт на Сході України триває, Росії, схоже, начхати,
як ставляться до північних сусідів українці.
Росія каже, що вона хоче "залізних, юридично обов’язкових гарантій" того,
що НАТО "ніколи" не прийме Україну. І не тільки це: Альянс має "зібрати свої манатки"
та відкотити своє розширення на Схід більш ніж на двадцять років назад
- до тих днів, коли навіть Польща чи країни Балтії ще не були членами Альянсу.
Росія йде ва-банк зі своїми вимогами та ультиматумами, усвідомлюючи,
що більшість, якщо не всі її вимоги будуть категорично відхилені Заходом.
Аналітики ламають голову, намагаючись зрозуміти, про що йдеться:
чи це Володимир Путін грає на свою внутрішню аудиторію, чи йдеться
про створення приводу для вторгнення, маючи змогу сказати,
що вимоги Росії проігнорували? На це запитання зараз ніхто не може дати відповідь,
особливо люди, які найбільше постраждали від скупчення російських військ тут, в Україні.
Протягом останніх місяців російські лідери вирішили ігнорувати Україну
та її представників, вибираючи натомість говорити зі США про Україну
за спинами українців. Росія стверджує, що їй загрожує співпраця НАТО
з українськими військовими, не кажучи вже про повноцінне членство в НАТО.
Але в Москві, здається, мало хто намагається зрозуміти прямий зв’язок
між зростанням підтримки приєднання до Альянсу всередині України
та риторикою Росії й анексією українських територій.
Але коли ти спілкуєшся з людьми, які живуть тут, на Сході України,
є певна суперечність. Якби російське вторгнення в Україну відбулося,
люди тут постраждали б першими. Але багато хто з них виглядає на диво спокійним.
Після майже восьми років боїв на порозі власних будинків із щоденними жертвами
люди тут звикли до розмов про війну, і в багатьох вже просто не вистачає сил боятися.
"Я повірю, коли на власні очі побачу російські танки", - кажуть вони.